[Music]
so funny in the commercial break the
band's plan you leaned over and you said
I want to play with a band that has
horns that has brass yeah I'm like you
could arrange that well I could actually
take these guys you can have one of them
I I want them all while the one in the
Hat okay you made the right choice it's
a little crazy we have I don't want to
get overly technical and I don't but I
don't think this is it I think the
hardest instrument to distinguish
yourself on is maybe the drums and yet I
don't I always know when it's you you
have the most distinctive sound and
rhythm of any player that I've ever
heard and I realized I think I read an
interview once where you said it's
because you sort of taught yourself and
you learned a few things the wrong way
well no I was born left-handed right and
my grandmother thought that was not a
good sign and so she turned me
right-handed so I write right-handed
anything else I do left-handed golf
whatever yeah and so I have a
right-handed kit but I lead with my left
that's what makes it weird because you
know I need time to heal understand to
do a fill you know he's high already you
can do this you can roll from the snare
to the top song and go all the way
around right where I can't do that right
because I've got a come under all the
time right but I can go this way really
cool yeah but what's amazing is that you
know as I said my kids listen to Beatle
music all the time so almost every day
I'm listening to your drumming and I
grew up listening to it and I'm always
hearing this these sequences which you
were just doing and I'm sure you weren't
even working it out beforehand you just
did it and now it's immortalized yeah I
never worked it out so I could never
work a fill out it comes in the emotion
of the song right and so I could never
double the fill you know I mean I
couldn't we put the track down and then
okay doubled I feel like I'd never do it
because it just came off whenever it
came
uguu yeah you couldn't duplicate the
emotional style I have you said before
the show you were saying that one of
your probably your favorite drum track
of the Beatles was rain right which
interests me cuz and I was thinking
about it that is just fantastic drumming
and for the time very different from
anything you'd heard before well it
wasn't so much from what I'd heard
before I feel it when I played rain it
was the first time I sort of played that
busy and the last time I played that
busy enough late like that again right
you know it's like one of those weird
tracks it was one of those great
opportunities though there is a on the
new album there is a you play a Buddy
Holly song Buddy Holly one of my
all-time heroes he had a huge influence
on yeah the you know the big influence
he was the start of rock and roll with
Eddie Cochran and Gene Vincent and of
course Chuck Berry and Little Richard my
personal hero you know so he was part of
that initiation of rock and roll for me
yeah you know he also he was before him
what Bill Daley was before him was
interesting is that Buddy Holly was one
of the only guys early on to tour he
toured and he did a tour of England and
so there's a lot of rock and rollers of
your generation who saw him on
television and Elvis didn't come over
other people didn't over well you know
Eddie Cochran came to play and it was
him and Gene Vincent and somebody else
would do in a tour of England and they
were gonna play Liverpool right and with
Rory storming the Hurricanes we were
gonna be on the same bill as your band
before we storm and anyway God rest his
soul he died before he got to Liverpool
and you know we didn't think oh god we
thought he could have waited till he
played Liverpool
it's tell you thing